first one this is an equation to solve
it you just need a little bit of algebra
right you can see Jake Jake you put this
up than you yeah Jake's giving us some
working here which is fantastic what's
the very first thing that he's done on
the first line you can see it
that's cheeky he's um he's added one to
both sides he's out of one to both sides
no numbers have moved anywhere he's
added one to both sides that seven then
becomes an eight
then he's divided and that's where he
gets his eight over three thumbs up yeah
did anyone provide their answers two and
two-thirds anyone just left it there no
I'm happy that's cool all right we'll
come back to this one because no one has
volunteered an answer for it just yet so
that's all right let's have a look at
this graph that was a he's given us y
equals 2x minus one
now I hurried him off from the
whiteboard before he provided a scale
but you can see he's very consistently
made it one mark is one unit right one
mark is one unit yep so you can see that
this point here what do we call that
where the graph intersects with this
axis what we call that the y-intercept
what is its value negative one is that
what it should be how can you tell that
it should be have a look yep okay
fantastic if you substitute 0 into X you
get y equals 0 minus 1 which is negative
1 and now the shortcut way is that I've
given this equation to you in slope
intercept form so the intercept is right
there I mean you can work it out the way
ugly worked out which is you have to
know how to do that but because I've
given to you this convenient way you can
actually just read it off what about the
two we know what the negative one does
what does the to do yeah very good so it
tells you the gradient it makes it
steeper which is why if we went across
one unit like this one unit to the right
you'd go up two units and that's where
you are okay
so that looks like one one and you can
find that by testing coordinates yeah go
away
okay then we've got the trig questions
now trig was the most recent topic but
to be fair it is the hardest topic than
we've ever done that's my opinion anyway
so have a look you can see the way that
a reap reap right yep how'd it go this
is use the sine rule okay now you guys
know when I use the sine what I always
draw things on my triangles to help me
see how to use it properly what things
do I draw I draw lines what kind of
lines do I draw I draw arrows thank you
so a is over here and our aim is matched
it up with sixty degrees why sixty why
not eighty or forty it's the opposite
angle okay then the ten is matched up
with sine 40 right or forty degrees
hence sign for you so that's how he uses
the sine rule ever side a equals B over
sine B does this look right does it look
like you checks out look okay for
thirteen point four seven do I have
agreement well done okay so last one one
B I got enough space over here does
someone want to walk me through what's
the first thing that I write down I'll
give you a tip it starts with the letter
B anywhere remember it may say go thank
you
I'm trying to work out what values of X
will solve this and I already reminded
you right at the beginning that there's
more than one
okay I'm gonna expect two now the way
you get both of those angles is through
this guy the base angle how do I find
the base angle the base Inc was not X
yeah I use shift right I go shift sign
this sine inverse of 1/2 that should
give you 30 degrees okay your calculator
should tell you that right sine inverse
of 1/2 will give you this third degree
angle okay now what do I do with that
no seriously what do I do with that I've
got to go somewhere don't I maybe draw a
diagram might help you what do I put on
this diagram or stations to central okay
so I'm looking for where sine is is this
positive or negative it's positive so
which which quadrant among you
first and second yeah are you with me
is it ringing bells so therefore first
and second quadrants so I want to look
at what does the base angle 30 degrees
what does it look like in those
quadrants that's what X is equal to okay
the first question it's an easy one
what's what's 30 look like in the first
quadrant it looks like that even what
about in the second quadrant it's gonna
be the supplement of that right 180 take
away so it's 150 there you go and sure
enough just like every other equation in
the world you can test whether you got
it right by putting your answers into
the original equations sine 30 will give
you this sine 150 will give you about a
game make sense yes okay so now put your
pens down and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna run through like the 60-second
version maybe 90 second version of what
I asked you to have a look at in the
videos but in case you did it because
not that crazy of an idea
they're heading you can make if you
haven't made one already is simultaneous
equations
and the simple idea I want to get across
to you is this right they're heading
down and then look up because I'm gonna
point to something on the board and
don't want you to miss it okay I'll just
wait till you've had the chance to write
those unfortunately long words and wait
till every eye is locked on the board so
you can see what I'm about to show you
great we're there okay simultaneous
equations look carefully at this
particular equation let's just get rid
of all this other stuff around it okay
see this equation one of the questions I
asked you to do was to draw me a picture
of it there it is right there okay so
this equation can be graphed this
equation can be thought of as a line so
if you say simultaneous equations what
you're really thinking about is
simultaneous whines lines that exist
that what is simultaneous to me at the
same time or as we're gonna see in the
same place so here are two equations
right they're both from the example in
the textbook these two equations both
correspond to lines okay so here they
are here's one and here's the other okay
now if you've got two lines then where
are they simultaneously existing and the
answer is yeah thank you
right they're both lines exist at the
same time at the same place
can you read look you've got coordinates
what is that point it's one one write
that down for me one one now one one is
shorthand right it's coordinates
shorthand for what's the first number
for it's an X and the second number is a
Y so when we just say one one what we
really mean is x equals one and y
equals one at the same time but that
takes a long time to say takes a long
time to write and that's why we just do
this because you know how obsessed
mathematicians are always short forms ok
but you can see that this makes sense of
these two equations if I put them in
they will both work let's have a look 3x
plus y equals 4 1 1 is on this one have
a look what happens to the left-hand
side it becomes alright in a different
color 3 times 1 which is 3 plus 1
because X is 1 and Y is 1 and sure
enough that equals 4 what about the
other equation X plus y equals 2 when I
substitute that in as well you get 1
plus 1 which is also simultaneously true
ok so that's all this means that's all
it means